how do you sell the vision
like when you say hey you know one day
we're going to be
what one day hey johnny
i want you to work on yourself in these
areas because one day
you're going to be able to
what is that well one day i'm gonna be
what sell me the vision how do you sell
me division when i'm in the meeting with
you or is it the complete opposite where
you say who cares about a nice car who
cares about a nice house who cares about
having a million in a bank who cares
about being rich who cares about going
to hawaii who cares about going to
europe who cares how do you sell the
vision of where the individual is going
and where the company is going
yeah yeah i i
i hear what you're saying and the way i
would think of it is like
do you tell somebody
that they should want lots of money
or do you tell somebody that they should
not want lots of money and my answer is
i don't tell people what they want they
decide what they want
and so i don't really i don't it's up to
them i know in general what the social
science says about human beings which is
the way people are motivated at the
highest level and the way the the people
that make the most important
achievements get find their motivation
is through internal drive they call in
intrinsic motivation as opposed to
extrinsic but basically
autonomy
mastery purpose and social connection
are the four strongest motivators on
earth but
something like money or title or
prestige
is a much more common motivator because
if you're motivated by money or title or
prestige or power
then you tend to get those things and
you tend to use those things to control
other people and also
just human nature
money prestige power those more
competitive type motivations
they are they're very enticing to people
they're alluring to people but they're
not as strong in terms of actually
causing people to do good work they're
short-term positive motivators but in
the long term they tend to make people
in general not every person there's
certainly exceptions but in general they
tend to make people kind of miserable
and unmotivated
and so what we do is instead try to
create a platform together whereby all
of us myself included
can do things that make us feel alive
can do things that make us feel meaning
and for us
what brings us together originally was
helping small businesses but secondarily
what when we said well why why do we
love helping small businesses so much is
because we like the little guy we want
to help the little guy and that's what
motivates us
[Music]